- It's nice to meet another
American Idol person.
- I know.
- It's funny, we've never met,
but I feel like it doesn't
matter what season you're from or
it's like a camp.
Like it's sometimes
when you run into people
- It is.
- I'm always like,
oh, hey, we don't know each other,
but we kind of do
'cause we're the same.
- Well and it's
you have a, like an
unspoken bond with everybody
who does Idol because
- Yeah,
it's like a connection.
- Yeah 'cause it's like
nobody else understands
what it's like to be on that show
- Yeah.
- and then you meet people
that you're like, you know
exactly what I went through.
- Yeah.
And what you just get thrown into,
it's crazy.
- Yeah.
- What season were you on?
- It was on season nine.
I always get confused
'cause it was in 2010.
So, but I was one of the
youngest on my season.
I was like 16, so.
- Wow.
- I went from singing like
at my high school talent show
to then being thrust into the show.
- Wow, I was 19, so I was
at least a few years older.
That's young.
- Yeah.
And I sang the same audition song as you.
- Oh, "At Last?"
- Yeah.
- Oh my God.
So here's the reason why I sang it is,
I literally didn't know it was a TV show
because it was the first season.
I had no idea what I was auditioning for,
I just thought it might pay
and I was singing it at a wedding.
and so I was like, I'll just
sing it 'cause whatever.
- Well, and--
- And I love that song.
- I love that song.
- Yeah.
- And I was like, I was the
young one with the old soul.
- Yeah.
- And then when we got
to the live shows the
judges kept telling me
that they wanted me to be younger
and in my head, I was like
young, who's young and fun?
Kelly Clarkson.
So--
- Oh, you sang,
what did you sing?
- I sang "Breakaway"
and unfortunately it was
my worst performance.
(laughing)